all right here is our uh
our top 20 2188 plus top 20
335 entered for right now
the top 50
there's our top 50
20 63
plus for the top 50.
we'll see how this goes
have some fun get some good games in
there
let's get ready to go
let's try to get eighth or b ooh seventh
maybe seven
all right
i am far
round number one
against i am far
i am i am far
we've played eight
fourteen games eight to six
he's gonna get a mover uh oh he's in the
dark quick first win
get the two
boom back to tournament who's in first i
don't know
all right another i am
another i am
okay conservative approach early on by
white
alrighty let's get this guy here
and a quick knight c6 we'll see in a
couple moves if i feel happy
with my position you gonna try something
critical i don't care about double death
pawns i care more about
making sure there isn't some
dangerous pressure
um
let's uh try to resolve this pin right
away
i want to get the queens up rook c8
gotta babysit
knight b3 is this some
some kind of theory
uh it's looking like some kind of theory
well okay
let's focus for a second if i chop the
knight's gonna take be a pest on these
two points
push knight here and then push again
um i'm gonna give that a
go i really want to get this move in
soon
oh i don't mind that move
all right this knight that's in my house
needs to uh
go i don't mind being castled
and now bishop here
given the chance
i might want to grab some
tempe against their bishop or
nah i'm going to go with this they might
be trying to undermine this point soon i
want to exchange off my doubled pawn
so okay so they're going they're going
quickly for the c4 point
let's take first
now suppose i ignore that
i may be able to get their rook i'm
going to try this
maybe might be
yeah i think i could uh get the the rook
here
it's gonna be tough let's go here
i have bishop here if rook there and if
rook here i can consider this and then
here if i think i could force the rook
to this square
they may simply take here get a couple
pawns for the exchange
huh we'll see
they're deciding on this or a rook move
they may have some idea of giving the
rook and then trying to activate here i
do always have a block on c7 so they are
going to take here first
i think i want to just snap that rook
off
yeah i'll take the rook
and i'm going to keep i want to
recapture with the pawn to restrict
these guys and let's swipe this guy so
they have
they have what
let's take a step up
knight's gonna i can't stop the knight
from going there so let's just
anticipate it
oh i forgot the bishop is on a dark
square too right
okay
that wasn't uh a good move to really be
giving my opponent
yeah i should probably get out over here
i guess this is looking like the safest
home for my king
i think their minor pieces are going to
be a little annoying
um
i don't know here right here i could
take the pawn so that the bishop's
probably gonna post up on this square
really
so oh they're gonna hit me with the
skewer
is that the plan man
i could kick my bishop
um yeah
not going well man not going well
this was not calculated
my bishop covers
so important detail
i think i want to get rid of that knight
if the if they dodge the rook exchange i
have h6 i got to go faster
i get a little something here
take this pawn
the bishop's really good
i'm really down on the clock
why not i should defend it like this
oh my goodness
don't play rook here
really really passive
really really passive
clock man clock man
oh
ah man
hmm
i didn't quite get
the position i wanted
uh i was hoping for a much cleaner
technique that's for sure
did not show uh very good technique
there
nope
is that a pawn
want to go uncastled i guess
don't hurt me
please don't hurt me
let's go here
all right
um
where do i want to go my king
hmm
i guess here
brooke to c8 and then
run my king
somewhere let's stick around over here
g4 i could take there i don't think
there's enough light squares around
where
i don't think my queen's going to be
getting trapped
feels too risky to go grab another pawn
safety first castle by hand he's taking
a pretty big hike towards the king side
okay
he's in the tank
uh let's go here a little bit more
central
hitting hitting this point
i could treat my
treat my queen as if she's a bishop i
could fall back
i'll go here it's in a pin there's no
knight h4
and maybe now i oh i could have
considered this
at what point
instead of h6 yeah
let's double up
keep on doubling
maybe that was better let's go for this
now
i don't have this um this square if uh
the b5 move came
still uh
go here i guess
clean's a little annoying
to be sure
let's maybe
flush that queen out of there i'm on the
night
i might have some
some fancy moves soon i think knight d4
knight d4 could mean could be a move
uh let's go here knight here i could
take
i do have a follow-up fork and a
decision if i
now rook here
if i try and get the two minor pieces
um okay
i could eventually kick that rook away
should i go here
and then here if they try to stay on the
seventh
now
i want to keep this square guarded
i am up a pawn
okay
feel much comfortable now
let me try this
tell you what i'm going to play here i
want to get this pawn on a light square
i got the entry points covered over here
playing a bit faster this game
which is good news
fell behind too far
last game
hello icelandic noob i see you in the
chat
alright we got some activity
i like taking like that
i could chop
get this pawn my rook is super active
might even try for me
i'll hit i'll take this first
this is tempting as well with this to
follow for me
it's looking good
oh
it's a bishop
all right they resigned where are we at
sixth pendulum swings
where are we at
okay
legenda
23
plenty of time to go
plenty of time remaining
148 let's try fianchetto h3
all right
let's play in the center
challenge their strongest pawn
all right now my bishop's eyes are
opened let's grab some space
centralize
you're really gunning for b5 here it's
almost always useful to get an h6
i would like to have what here
i am welcome to
fill in the blank
i am welcome to
a light square bishop exchange for sure
let's take a step up i have to watch out
for forks
i could play this move
but i like
going with the non-committal stuff first
okay
what about driving the knight back right
now
is that a thing
um i'm going to drive that knight back
tonight here i may want to
take on this square first
how do i want to approach this i don't
want the knight arriving here
let's take on this square first
i feel like a white knight on f4 is more
annoying than a knight here
okay i could consider capturing
with the
bishop okay i could take with the knight
if i take with the bishop trying for a
fork
they're gonna swipe my knight first
tell you what i'm going to get rid of
this
annoying piece
and plop my knight right in the center
out of
out of the bishop's view
probably fall back with this guy
and i'm restricting the queen this
knight is uh
it's got to be a pretty annoying piece i
think
i could consider a push
my knight has a check it's not a good
one though
let's be aggressive
instead of this
strictly defensive move
all right suppose i take a step up and
remind
black that this could be a little a
little tender
okay they're
they're being they're being cautious
let's just make a i don't know i'm
making some soft moves here
okay the bishop's backing off huh
let's pinpoint this guy now
i got this square covered
step up with the king they're playing
fast
i continue to push
suppose i push
let's do it
and like a fork
giving up a big square but maybe i maybe
i crashed through here i thought about
doing this first
playing this first
let's let's back off
it's not easy to kick my knight away oh
i have this move as well
oh i could really
increase the pressure on g3 this has my
attention for sure
i chop here first right
chacarone
oh if knight takes i can't take here
that's that's okay though
all right what about now
where does my bishop want to be
i'm gonna say here so my queen is
cleared out for this square
got the killer bees
maybe now you do this
okay
um
well i don't want that pawn to fall
he's kind of he's kind of good
i guess we run it like this
i'm looking to improve my queen there's
not really a great improvement
with my bishop my king
peace improvement
is what i'm looking at oh i'm also
eyeing up a back rank square which is
nice
all right let's go here in case the
knight wants to move and
queen is excited about giving a check
i think if the knight moves there could
be some trouble is there trouble now i
think there's trouble now back rank
issues
they were coordinated on this square but
not after queen g4
so this is this is checkmate
queen bishop block we just vacuum them
up
all right we got a w
velociraptor rex
okay
is in first so far for the team i see
messy answer
messy answer has played many times i
believe
okay we have candidate master very high
rated
candidate master
uh 2-2 is our score
oh i think i'm recalling a recent game i
played
maybe not
oh centralize
it should be an even position
hello stl chess player let's keep the
file opened
take with the knight
or the rook
let's take with the rook
there's a couple of ways it can be
struck at i don't know if they're any
good
i like keeping the pin
queen does not feel so comfortable
um
what to do okay this knight can't move
how about we centralize
how bad can that be
now i'm threatening this
just realized okay they defended that
what's useful
what is useful
maybe i could insist on a capture here
if this knight moves maybe my knight
moves currently they're competing for e5
so you go here maybe i go there all
right
i take this guy first i think so
and now move forward
is there anything
wrong with that
i don't know a little little pressure
just a little pressure on uh
f7
they're solid
my knight is unprotected
my bishop is unprotected
all right i have to take with the
there should be some tactic here no
not in a pin
no like
is this too
i don't know
is this too what
the knight can't move throw a check and
get the exchange in the end
i'm clearly lining up only one idea i i
may give up the bishop just to get the
knight and the rook activity uh knight
versus bishop ending active rook
i still need a flight square
but i think the rook activity is the is
the important thing oh they're
threatening me
all right suppose i go here though is
this a blunder possibly
i'll be on the queen in the night the
queen can move and hit my knight though
maybe i plant the knight on d6 though
and say i'm super annoying to your rook
all right you're running it like that
still feels like there should be
something for me here
okay
um
i'm gonna get activated with my queen
they do have coordination here
but i'm on their knight and my rook is
covered on d1 so i could take the knight
if rook d8
otherwise that would sting just trying
to get really active with my queen right
now
if knight here here i don't want this
rook to get activated too soon
this would be tempting but rook d8 queen
recaptures i need a flight score i want
to
i don't know
i think i want to
couldn't stop the rook to da move in
short
so what's the story oh you know what
they're concerned about
knight knight c no knight c knight c5 b4
i'm blundering my queen
okay
um
rook c7 for starters queen c7
stop knight c4 pressure on these two
points control the knight
oh queen exchange
did not expect that
play against a structure
pawn grab
going for a pawn grab i guess
uh we're just training he gets the pawn
back i'm down on the clock
i get a pawn back though how's this
working out
it's not easy
let me get a second pawn need to
my kink could stop that pawn yes he
could stop it
i check
i have a pawn i could get run in here
fighting back on the clock now
oh
it's a one king upon ending
okay plenty of time
tough fight tough fight okay another
game man you can barely breathe uk chess
bomber mm sanchez chess very nice
pack leaders for the team
okay i'm going to try this uh
kind of a d a quick detour
i guess we have uh
i'm not sure it's not a carrot con
carro con in disguise
kbg1
next opponent here
all right give me okay let's let's try
this
oh
really
you're okay with that pin
let's get some more development in
should i have captured i don't know i
mean
they get an open file they castle down
the queen side they probably like that
g-file let's take with the pawn i think
i'm
maybe slightly better here
all right now now you're really
now you're asking for trouble maybe i'm
going this way
so i don't have to worry about a rook
bringing some heat towards my king
because my king is just not there
let's get out of any possible pins
trying to get rid of your bishop
can't allow that to happen so easily
maybe
i could go wherever i want with my
knight
and it's hitting their queen
i think i want to ask this guy maybe you
know maybe
the bishop ends up taking my knight not
too much i could do about that let's see
i'd like a dark square bishop exchange
and then planting a knight in one of
these two
let's go here
they're gonna end up taking with the
pawn though right
okay
let's see how this goes
bishop's hanging right now
wow really
okay let's get one rook off
and now duck this uh threat bishop here
and we do that by playing here
clean here stay active
defend this pawn
it's a little annoying i still have some
problems to solve the knight is under
control i like that
i wasn't too concerned about that move
defend the pawn and maybe i maybe i take
this guy
there's no fork i always have queen a3
so
so a3 chop b4 i could take the pawn get
out of the fork with the check
also this here i have a check and then i
can get the bishop
i don't really have any concern over
rook d8 my queen covers that if the
bishop and rook tried to coordinate on
d8
okay
all right so still i think this is a an
important pawn to get rid of
i could consider knight takes pawn
they're tricks
are there tricks
i am on the bishop
knight d6 shouldn't be
shouldn't be anything
get some piece off i had to i looked
briefly at b4 but i would just take the
bishop
so now
this pawn is defended indirectly
if they try a check
all right how about we take a step up
remove any good checks by white
and drive the knight away
find a different square you're not
welcome here
um
let's try that
oh i don't have a lot of time
flush that night away that was probably
not a good idea i should have went
hunting for that pawn
the rook's covering the base points they
it's a little kind of tricky to break
down
a check here
i want this square
stay central with my queen if i can
control the knight
the knight's really under control
okay i get a pawn
and now i can get this passer running
they should be completely winning
knight is under control
i can get fancy now
a little fancy
get out of the way
give a check
keep it squeaky clean
all right
a little nervous about stalemates
all right
not a lot of
gas remaining in the tank there 1.6
we're at 316.
um
yeah 316
275 274th
novo oh who am i playing it's okay trio
fan fantastico
i'm forgetting to look at the team name
there
playing against trio fan fantastico and
friends alright
one of the newer teams welcome
they're in the tank
all right let's go here
i'm not looking to fight for the e4
square so much early on
but rather with bishop e2 i'm ready to
play bishop f3 one day and challenge
this piece
uh this piece that i think is their best
piece
also
by delaying knight c3 before castles i
don't have to
worry about a serious pin or anything
all right
[Applause]
i'm going to try this
fracture the structure i do get the dark
square bishop maybe they get that pawn
at the end but i would have a a strong
bishop as compensation i'm ready to
neutralize their light square bishop so
all right let's let's follow through
with this right away
my knights currently stand on pretty
good squares
happy about that
probably recapture with the queen
develop a new piece this is a nice
fallback square
if uh
this starts to concern me having doubled
pawns
i'm on the rook for right now so
okay that's awkward
they can't feel too happy about that
move
um i'm gonna i'm gonna fall back
um
yeah it's concerning me a little bit the
chop night here night here i think that
pawn would
would fall
so
it's complete development
i could have i guess considered this
move i don't know
all right but things are kind of smooth
here i like my structure my knights are
sitting pretty
where's the pawn break
d5 is
nearby
here this might fall one day you know
here's the thing if this if if the
position opens up this rook is not going
to be too happy
he's out of play
so what about d5 right now open things
up this guy's gonna be excited now that
g6 is in
d5
um
let's get some let's get this rook
working first
these sacrifices aren't
aren't anything to be concerned about
anything to be concerned about i don't
think
um chop here bishop's gonna take here 94
stuff is that what the the big plan is
let's let's
let's go here
that's covered
let's go a little faster
i don't know about my last move okay so
queen's not getting trapped is she isn't
this guy going to be a giant pest soon
get this in
oh
oh i didn't consider that
and a push here
again things are opening up this rook
even if they win a pawn i should it
shouldn't be
you know i should have some compensation
i don't want to see the night dive in
here
oh
all right this is going to be the way
you can get a pawn back
and i have the safer king at the end of
all this major piece specific look at
this
these guys are excited
let's chop here
take that b-pawn
i'll take the b-pawn
queen really wants this one
three to two majority
i like that
so what's the plan i'd like to get one
rook off
get rid of some pressure
it's gonna run it like this
it might be
trying something on the g or h file so
let's start with this then i got three
defenders
now let's get running with these guys
time time time time time
let's go
that's as far as you're gonna go
keep going
and get the rook at the end if they try
the two rooks for the queen queen check
gotta go fast er
time
here
here
there's a pin if they try this
they'd end up in a pin after i recapture
they're in the tank
they're not gonna move
whoa serious lag right there
let's get the queens off
okay back to tournament whoo
tough tough tough
okay where are we at where are we at
where are we at okay benny
uh benny benny bunny
let's try the kara khan against benny
mad quick chess i just saw you out the
corner of my eye what's going on mad
quick chess
thank you for the tier one
four months in a row now man
benny and the jets yeah
benny and the jets
you got a block critical line g4 knight
there
feeling the feeling the heat on on c6
oh i think i i could have played e6
first
all right wow you're really going after
my throat
what did i do to you man
yeah i should have had e6 in first that
was
silly
all right
all righty
i want to have whoa they're going that
way
yeah makes sense
[Music]
let's go here
[Music]
yeah all right i guess i guess we
we play it like this
i don't know
is it cozy here or what
h5 or not h5
what about knight g6
they're they're really trying to get
into this square
i'm going knight g6 rookie eight
definitely be taking with the pawn if
they take my knight
all right what about
huh
i don't know i gotta make a move
all right knight here
let's see if we can get a fork huh
bishop back there is most natural
all right let's open it up
try and get my rook activated this guy's
not playing yet this knight's gonna dive
in soon
got something happening on f4
get rid of that
so how's this going to play out i think
i'm i'm coming out ahead somehow i feel
like i'm close to winning a pawn
oh there's that move
all right let's let's take here first or
let's take here first
all right am i not just running a pawn
all right
g5
okay they're bishops far better than
mine it's mine's staring off on a
ridiculous diagonal
i wanna i wanna get some check in
clean takes here i have
no i don't have that
all right let's let's be extra cozy here
i am up upon no it feels like i'm up two
pawns these three restrict these three
now we're now we're coordinated i had a
check there okay let's get the queens
off this is
this should be a clean conversion
let's go
let's go pawns
guard my base points
go for this
improve my king as well
oh why'd i run it like that i forgot
about that king move
oh that was really bad
i may i may be
lucking out a little bit here
still winning
still winning
not the cleanest technique but it should
be enough
all right
plenty of time in the tank
gonna get this
all right
our team's currently in seven uh seventh
place 434
trying to catch 461 that's the closest
uh kc's team king's crusher
vanya
all right one hour 17 remaining
i am
in
171st
right now
uk chest bomber 29 mouse sleeping one
two three who's that
i haven't seen that account before
having a good tournament
rated 1955 blitz
putting up 28 points nice
all right this rook move this is a
little bit soft now
i'm gonna play here pre-move a queen
queen blender
gotta go back home
never feel comfortable do i increase the
pressure knight g5
try and bring the pain
nah
they're gonna get some tempe against my
bishop and my queen
but that should run out
and in the end i think everything is
i think you look to this point and say
you should always kind of be better
let's get rid of this knight
got the big center
so what does this mean
maintaining this structure right here
this guy isn't too happy
all right let's go apon i'm long term
looking for some target on the queen
side
could have also considered this okay so
um decision here to take or maybe play
here and maybe one day this guy
gobbles up this pawn or my rook gets
that pawn
i'm gonna try for this a6
trying to
looking a little deeper okay
um how about we start with this move
get out of this pin
let's go here i could block a bishop
there i need a flight square
i'm also uh looking at this move too
if c5 there's a problem there dark
square bishop exchange that's an
interesting
interesting decision there
tell you what i will take that
kind of opening up my queen's eyes a
little bit
maybe get that into that f6 square i
still need a flight square it's likely
going to be h3 maybe h4
this pawn is pinned
i'm gonna win it
i did consider not taking this bishop
because i still wanted to keep a piece
around that could potentially get this
a7 pawn
all right there's still an issue here
how you saving that pawn
i could put three attackers on that
start with this queen takes pawn
let me be careful here here takes here
there's a check
lose my queen
c5 queen takes pawn takes rook takes
i think i'm going to enter that ending
i know they have a trick
but i'm
looking forward to
getting these guys
yeah
this guy
is what i want all right time for flight
square
i'll go with this to restrict this guy
now that was a bad decision by me
okay
okay uh the rook is frozen right now or
i get a pawn
should be about even
my rook is really active really really
active
yeah
gotta go back
it's not fun
it may be necessary
all right i want to be able to make some
inroads with my king
no i don't want to give that f3 pawn up
so making some progress
save the pawn
now we're there
all right um
let's come back for a second
i don't want that well i don't want to
drop one of my pawns so easily okay now
we got this
all right go here
all right check
got rook checks
go after this guy
can't stop the that pawn now
all right they resigned
whoo okay four oh look at how close only
three back
um
only
oh
we're less than 10 away from
stepping up to
two spots
nice
um
[Applause]
let's play sicilian
i'll go here
i don't want to
fall back with my bishop just yet
that's a bit surprising
giving up their dark square bishop
okay
well
let's play this structure
and i'm gonna see if i can make this guy
flinch
let's babysit
d4
okay
stop knight c4
i have to worry about a bishop coming
here
i could eye up this square yeah
knight on that c5 square let's let's do
a little dance
get out of the line of fire queen can't
go too far she has a responsibility
um
all right i didn't
consider that one you're stopping me
from castling
yeah you do have a point
huh okay
let's go here
here
and now i'm ready to cancel
i can't put more pressure on this point
is there some line with this and then
here
i have other ways to get
to to complete my development their
night is out of play okay castles it is
so now i'm ready to fight for this uh
file
run
i should be better here
how much i don't know if i get h6 in i
think it could be a big problem
for black
they may be afraid to play h6 because
of sacrifices here
okay my queen on g7
can we make that happen
step one what do we do
just want the rooks off their bishop is
not playing tall pawn right now
that's why i was looking earlier at the
f4 move not saying it works but it's at
least a way for its eyes to open up and
start questioning light squares in my
camp
so i'm ready to double up
trade rooks
eventually my queen will find a way
and i i think black will be on the
defensive at some point they're gonna
try to get the queens off
but i should be able to slither in with
moves like this
eyeing up e7 now tough to control the
queen
in the semi-open position
okay
well
let's begin
if i put my bishop on f6 then all of a
sudden simply getting to the back rank
and it's
it can be it could be game over
okay
let's go here maybe improve my king a
little bit
oh you know what i should try get my
knight to g5 oh i'm definitely taking
that
let's get that guy out of there
now if the queens are off a knight here
wins
okay
i'm on that pawn
i don't want to take because it opens up
a square here let's let's glue the
knight in
first no rush for taking this pawn
the queen would have some checks as well
okay
stop bishop here
pawn is poison got forks
okay we got the queens off
i don't i could control these guys
let's take this guy
yeah
and
play here pressure on this supporting
that
check here
keep this covered
and it should be smooth sailing no entry
points for their king
pawns control it or their
pawns get in the way of
their king improving
okay 5 34. ooh
we're in a good spot
or is fifth or sixth
still a little over an hour to go
mhz
now let's try c5
all right coming at me here
lively in the center
who's gonna blink first with the chop
okay i'm gonna blink first
yeah let's take
let's get in b5
bishop b7
um
chop first
yeah i'll chop first
and then bishop bishop here pretty good
piece
you may go here or back off
this is more threatening
um break the pin i don't really mind so
much if my pawns are doubled
uh i don't i don't know how weakening it
really would turn out to be for my king
side i have a knight
that could uh
in a way supplement the g pawn on g6 and
the pawn on f6 does a good job
controlling the knight
let's let's castle
i got two bishops pointing at their king
okay so here we are
i feel like i want to just take that
knight
now no let's go here
i'm i'm giving greater weight to my
light square bishop than my dark square
bishop here i have some nice dark square
control and a nike that could jump into
f4 he's under control i feel like he's
under control
king stepping up here it should be nice
and cozy centralized put pressure on
this point i could already look to win a
pawn
should i
grab the knight and then grab d4
defending f6 at the end of that
that night doesn't even bother me though
i don't know let's get this rook here
wrong rook possibly should have been the
other one
yeah i think i went with the wrong rook
and i i maybe should have
gone ahead and won the d-pawn
i think the rook is slightly awkward
awkwardly placed in this simplified
ending they may try to pitch this pawn
i want the c file though
d5 is
is something
if not d5 my knight gets to d5 soon and
okay so let's let's do that right now
[Music]
let's do that right
yeah let's let's go here first
the knight moves then i get to the
seventh
okay now we transfer the knight
pretty sure if i if i played this first
this check was a little annoying
now i have uh
the f8 square at least
does this rook a little bit
a little awkwardly placed now
oh they're asking for trouble forks and
stuff right i win the rook
if they went here i stepped up i
eventually forced the rook to the light
square they resigned
okay oh eugene
next opponent
an hour two remaining
some quick pressure against this pawn
and i would defend like this f3 then
there's a pin i cannot rely upon my
knight as a defender of d4
all right so
do we give that knight a boot
let's say
nay to that so
i don't have much experience with this
structure
tell you what i'm going to close it
close it a little bit and work to
try and restrict this knight
i'm
kind of
preparing to go queen side i mean if if
they go with f4 i haven't committed my
king on the king's side i don't i don't
really don't mind this too much
so i'm gonna go queen side put my knight
on d3
queen side it is do i insert h4 first
um
let me get h4 in
so now i mean if they really want this
then they have to give me the file
okay this is an important moment
when i say i don't castle in either
direction now i'm going to hang onto
this pawn
and maybe i go with a3 and b4 while my
rook is still there
in the a file okay so i still have i
could maybe go queenside now
um
let's move fast this is going to be a
lengthy game likely
strategic
um
let's go queenside
here
i'm playing fast
and i'm kind of floundering here they're
trying to get rid of their dark square
bishop
yeah i'm i'm not playing this well
nope nope nope nope
let's go here
too many king move or too many king
moves yeah too many king moves too many
pawn moves
they reorganized their pieces pretty
well there
let us see some sacrifice here possibly
there's still so many pieces on
let's get this here
let's open it up a little bit
oh that was really bad by me
all right
i should have went g4 in one swing
says a pawn
all right
let's let's give this a shot
oh i'm thinking it's a i get the
exchange or something
not quite
they're giving me that
all right
oh
oh i have a check i'm kind of lucking
out with this capture
this
okay
43 seconds
why did i not
what was i thinking there
i wasn't thinking is the thing
my king needed to step over
alright i could safely resign this one
i shouldn't have castled queen side
i should have went with what i
my first instinct which was to keep the
king in the center and play a3 and b4
that's my quick
thought on how i could have maybe played
that better
after the defeat
my quick post mortem
should have went with my instinct there
my instincts yeah
what kept me from doing that
what was my train of thought just then
i don't know
all right
let's get back on the horse
prepare to
negate these guys bishop g6
the queen won't feel comfortable on c2
for too long
like right now she might go to b1
okay
so if i go here now i'm threatening some
stuff
knight here here
this is the big one on d form
keep the file opened
they're trying to remove the knight and
then win that
pawn take towards the center
okay
um
i can get this in there's a pin
the bishop is pinned to the queen
to be a little careful of the knight
the knight on g5 after
if they take on g6 a knight on g5 and a
queen right here
but that takes many moves it's not
it's not really clear
okay
i take here first
let me take here now
make sure that light square bishop is
gonzo
let's fall back now
and we have a break in the end what have
all these queenside pawn advances
netted me
a target
this guy
so let's hit him
oh did i just allow this
i could take here first
all right let's do it like this so i
still have something to bite out it's
not
much but it is something
they have an isolated pawn in a super
simplified position
all right
i feel like i should just remove this
right away but what do i have to play
for then
let's try this first increase the
pressure on d4
i still need a flight square what kind
of flight square maybe maybe i should
have considered g6 instead of queen d6
to stop this move all together
all right let's go here knight c6 is a
little annoying
let's freeze these guys
no g4
knight six queen here
i'm also paving the way for possibly uh
not anymore
but if there was a quick queen exchange
stop any sacrifices on g6
oh you're hitting here okay i should i
should probably get this now
and offer a queen exchange
like this
i don't want to see the queen
get to f6 so i'd like to watch over my
dark squares yeah
and this base point that's
that's another thing so now
i can get activated with my rook but i
don't want to pivot along the rank just
yet
let's go here
and
what about
here
kind of setting something up like this
oh really
unprotected pieces
wow i did not see that one
yikes
queen here with the push push first
there first
cannot see that d5 move
so here here
queen takes pawn uh what do we have here
fall back
so passive
man my time my time my time
what am i doing
losing
oh i didn't want to go there
i wanted f6
ah terrible mouse slip
it's gonna come down to a mouse race and
i felt like i could have won the mouse
race
oh
654
654 662 672.
okay
50 remaining
okay
uh who's this oh crest book chess club
still not uh
in the habit of looking who i'm playing
against what team
this player is representing
crestbook chess club
we'll take once
chop here
and get rid of their light square bishop
do i get the big center or not
i can improve my center with the capture
on c3
ah man how do you lose that last game
too
that d5 pawn break
is what exposed my king
hmm
[Music]
certain
games sting and that was one of them
ones where you should never lose it
should be a two result position the
whole way
no take now
this night's starting to concern me a
little bit
put some
pressure on him
give the queen responsibility stop any
night jump should the position open up
and it can in a blink on black's terms
all right
it's closed so let's keep an eye on the
night
i have a central majority now that this
guy has decided
to take a step they have a three to two
on the queen side i have something in
the center maybe i could get the center
going
i don't have to go that way i could
still play for a5
play to create a target on the queen
side
they're in the tank
let's see
50 seconds
they're really thinking this one through
start with that
rook has no business being on the c file
no business
flight square time
now let's just improve the night
with this h6 movement it's not easy to
kick my knight away
he'll land on an even more annoying
square possibly
all right he's dancing
knight f4 he's gonna find some
some square to be a pest
i could glue him in
maybe
flush that knight away now i like i
think i like this idea of flushing the
night away
i could also consider rook here
now let's flush the night away
revisit this move
oh why
i don't need that
let's keep going
all right now kick the knight and i'm
ready to glue my my knight in here it's
just a matter of when
when do i want to do that
i give that square up if i do that
let's go here
here here
i want something to bite out
a6 stops a6 let's keep pressure here i
have a fork potentially so
one of their majors is restricted to
defending e7 in many lines
all right let's get the passer
their knight is on a good square
must admit
let's stop f5
glue my night in
it's going to be a time when
all right
695 698 ooh
oh it's the guy that beat me
who does he play for a crest book okay
a berserk okay a double berserk game
gotta get my hand ready my hand's going
a little cold here
are we going to have a similar
all right we're bo we're in bullet mode
what's the bullet rating
22.78
this is still bullet time control right
90 seconds we're following the same game
same game i'm gonna take with the pawn
this time
maybe not now
looking for three points here
let's go here let's immediately address
this knight position
all right very similar to the last game
are they going to try to attack me
let's get this minority attack rolling
do not mind the double death pawns okay
that that concerns me though
it's defended
really bringing the heat here
i gotta keep it closed
this is falling apart
time time time
they are in a better position far and
away
i don't know what to do
on the rook
oh man down to the wire they had me on
the ropes there
i had to sit and wait
never fun
when are they going to open up the
position when are they going to make the
capture okay oh they berserked i was
going to do berserk back
i wasn't fast enough
right this guy's playing another
crestbooker
all right
crest book
chess club
see if we could
have some accident happen
on the king side right now is there
supposed to be an accident
chop here
is now the accident
um
knight takes pawn rook takes
bishop takes i might as well try
something
like this mix it up
i don't know get this guy going
no rush
with taking that rook it's still pinned
you ready for d5
how about we flush the knight so rook's
still in a pin
all right knight here i take here king
takes the knights defended i i didn't
see that move
no didn't see that one
i want d5
like yesterday
oh
totally missed that move
let's get the queens off
this guy going
some activity
money a7
they're very passive
they're down on the clock so
i think things are looking pretty good
their knights are under control
take another step
this guy
knight here i have a pin i just realized
here
all right but now
now we can give this sh take here give
the check and then push
that has to go there
let's guard that guy oh they thought i
was going to take right away all right
there he resigned
7 49 7 51. oh it's really close trying
to get that next spot
pawn resigned
okay that's helpful 753 755 758
we're nearly in sixth
really close for sixth
all right let's see if we can get this
one here
uh d5 i guess
c5
given
giving me the bishop pair
all right
yes this is a super good structure
king belongs there
knight belongs on f5
all right what's that queen that's
that's just some quick flashy move she
doesn't do anything from that square
i'm not afraid of that move
i like this maneuver
the knight right there is looking pretty
juicy
let's dive in
and challenge them
all right
i have a target
hang on
hang on
all right well i have an isolated pawn
to play against
let's go here
put the bishop on f6
okay
um
[Music]
i need to find an accurate move
no
one other pieces is going to be really
active
centralize the queen
take with the knight
okay
i'll take the draw
yeah they played really fast and they
were going to soon have a lot of
pressure on
my f7 point
okay
i feel like i was just a move or two
away from having a really good position
there
where i could try and press my opponent
all right well d6 is a little
soft there okay
take with the queen maybe my queen could
be a pest on h6
oh here
where's our night go whoa they're going
uncastled
brave
super brave
take with this
knight on d6
knight on d6
knight on d6 they're allowing a knight
on d6
okay
they are very solid
just going to lose this pond soon
i almost want to just dive into d5
oh let's try it
oh they could take with the rook
thinking they could they take with the
bishop first
that was really bad
that was really really bad
okay they have a full night
yeah
that's kind of
kind of an issue
i got that a pawn though
there
now bishop here
maybe
gotta try to push through
knight c5 they're gonna swipe upon and
can you catch this pawn
i should probably
calculate soon
okay
if i push
how do you stop him
take with the queen first
push queen d6 or d8 queen takes pawn
and push first
well
okay they have to give the check i
missed the check
clean here
clean a7
need two more moves
the queen takes g6
i try that
um
here
time
a7 a18
thought he should be able to time burn
me unfortunately
oh
yeah unfortunate
well it was a bad sacrifice to begin
with
um okay sixth eight
twenty
21.
fifth is probably not going to happen
over 100 away
okay okay okay under 30
remaining
a bogo indian
chopping jumping
chop and jumping
okay let's get my c pawn contributing
knight c6
no
all right f pawn
f4 yes
got f4 in
why am i so happy about that
uh i wanted h5 i wanted h5 let's try it
again
am i winning a pawn
i'm getting a creed i'm creating a past
pawn
here's the plan chop here take with the
bishop for sure
now get in the spot to challenge their
best piece
a knight on f3 he needs to go
now as otherwise g5 so i might have to
work around a knight on f5 for a move or
two
all right
now let me go here oh rook up and over
i'm stopping any night transfer here
i like this idea
and then this idea
and the rook up here
if i go here eventually there's this
little
a5 stuff so i may want to just defend
along a rank for a little bit
because
i don't know let's go here they're in a
pin
and pivot here is the best spot right
behind this pawn you're ready to push
them
there we go just like this
and i'm gearing up for this move
oh
man
all right let's focus i didn't see that
but
do i have something knight takes knight
and they're getting they have a fork i
should still be better though
i should still be better
if i could sack the queen for rook and a
minor piece i would totally go for that
in this position but i don't see how
that's
really working
all right all right all right you got me
with that little trick
again i think i should still be better
here
take with the
king or do i
they should i don't think they should
take right away all right keep the file
alright they're clean
let's go here
sneaky man
stopping my rook from getting to b7
should still be winning
i'm entering what get out of here with
that draw no way
kidding me
no way
queen's ought to play
tall clean said tall pond she's not
doing anything
there's no entry points
pick off this a pawn first
i don't care about the apon
i want more we're going for mates
you got the mates
time time time is not on my side
i get this pawn if the rook moves
yes that's a big pawn really big pun
now they should all collapse
the wheels are in motion
the pawns in the rook should do it alone
yep they're running
mate threat
it's
mate oh okay yeah that that little
sacrifice stunned me there
uber in six 8 72 870
oh it's close trio
i
gotta keep the streak
come on those of you playing for the
team keep the streak
don't get extinguished
you gotta play against frankenstein now
all right give me a break
give me a break
i'm not a big kit kat fan i can go for
snickers right now
though
oh
let's liven it up
crazy f pawn
you're not safe queen
you're not safe there
i don't know let's see what you do you
can take that phone
put you in a pin
i just
just ready to go what if i go here let's
play that
no
let's let's let's uh be a little careful
let's let's go here no rush
king on g2 bishop
all right let's fall back
king on g2 still is a cozy home queen on
f3 bishop on f3
i'm gonna take
once
or twice
what do i do
all right
take my apon
if you want the a pawn i at least get
the file
try and get this guy
b2 is a
is covered by my queen i have good
coordination
i could remove that knight whenever i
want
still
give you an opportunity there okay
um
let me try this
take it a moment when there isn't that
move okay
let's give this check i'm winning a pawn
i'll take it
yeah i still don't care about my
opponent
block with the queen
yep
all right it's a pawn race
run pawn
run
improve the king
a hair
give a check
let me check with the rook
oh
i hang up that square now
get that a pawn
check that way when i take here i have
c6
i have to defend this pawn
i'm up a clear pawn now
babysit this for a second
hmm
drive that king back
my king is cut off i don't like that
should be a draw
yeah
put the king right there
all right i'll try and play some moves
here
okay they have way too much time i was
already resigned there
okay where are we at oh we have a
decent lead 12 points
908
uh mm sanchez chess having a very good
tournament 59 points so far
uh who we got here fiona's fight club
i haven't been looking at the top three
i'm not sure if fiona's fight club up
there
probably
all right there's some sacrifices if you
go to c5
um
i'll work on the d4 square
i'm employing now a dark square strategy
i'll i'll voluntarily
chop that guy
um
let's go here
ctrl d4
stop any pin
have them work a little bit harder
before they get in f4
there's a pin
let's jump in
now let's get a little crazy with the
h-pawn
okay
wasn't expecting that move
control the knight
get a new square for the bishop
d4
um
i guess
my knight on d7 is a little clumsy
all right
should be a stable home bishop on c5
this knight is under control by my pawn
i'll castle
knight on f6
kind of interesting knight on f6
yeah i mean if you take here i take here
and i don't have any concern over a pin
if you tried the pin right now mine i
could take
rook to a2
i start to coordinate on f2 seems seems
useful
knight on g4 could be something as well
how well positioned is that bishop on
that square i don't think so well placed
i'll
i'll take and offer
bishop exchange
and i want that
how about we break in the center this
bishop has gone elsewhere
it's not controlling d5 i have good
pieces
let's open it up
okay oh i missed that move
okay
push
two knights versus two bishops
i could pin the knight
let's try the pin first
and rook to d8
they're in the tank
okay
well let's let's go now at least i get
to recapture and i have a tempo against
the queen my g4 check and surface oh i'm
liking my position
if i have the two knights versus two
bishops
i get on these squares i think
it's interesting move
um
prove how do i do this
let's go here
look at that d3 square i guess
i don't want to take and bring that
bishop out
giant pest i want i want to maintain my
knight on f6 he's
super glue for my king side
this control this controlled by my
knight who could i improve what's
unprotected by white
i don't know
i want to dive in here i could maybe
focus on f2
let's start with that
maybe knight into this square
try to get into these light squares a
knight on the e5 square i'm on c4 right
now
okay
if i take here there's queen takes
knight
extra sneaky man
i have a check
let's go with the check
okay
said a gotta go with b i guess
gotta watch out for back ranks now this
knight is killing me
here
wow man wow
at night oh man what am i doing
that night's so scary
oh man
that night on g5 is so scary
963 950 13 minutes remaining
okay okay okay okay
maybe i have a chance for top 100
and 100 in first place lestree
it's last tree is this a gm
maybe
an untitled gm
i'm recalling a lestree i should have
played knight d2
yeah knight d2 okay
still get a chance to get that one in
there without any
problems
all right um
i'll go this way
i don't want to have the niko here
kind of passing with my last move
prepare to get out of a pin in case
there's a capture here okay yeah so
now i guess i'll go here
ready for bishop h6 as soon as the night
retreats or there's something where
there's no longer knight h5 do i go with
this then i have to worry about that
um get out of a pin
what about
i like this actually
should i have done that
another point
after they went uh h5 was that a move
i think i want to take and have it
opened up a little bit
i think i need some
some breathing room
ready to plant a night here bishop here
okay
which night though
i'm gonna go with this one
wasn't my first choice
but i don't want to see a quick knight
b3 into this square
this is unprotected but it could be
poison in many many positions it is up
on the same diagonal as their king
i have pressure on d6 but i am in a pin
i was not expecting that
okay
um how about this and break the pin i
feel like i'm
slowly
improving my position
all right
all right let's take and plant the
bishop right here
the better bishop
safer king
all right i'll take that
try and get try and get these pawns oh
a4 wasn't hit
anyhow this belongs here
how do i make progress
not sure
i should have considered this maybe
okay
get the flight square in
i should be better i think
safer king
not sure what that's doing
this would have been a more useful move
run a pin this may be a move at some
point
under 40 seconds each
um
let's try this
check i don't mind
take here
here
here and then maybe a check another
check
another check
oh
i was able to check my way there
exploiting that f5
rook ooh decent lead what are we at 15
15 point lead
over
uh seventh
frankenstein again
okay this one should count for the
tournament
let's go with this right now
all right let's liven it up different
structure
really
which way am i gonna go
um
king side
my center supported by two pawns
centralize all my pieces hopefully they
can't
break it down so easily
here comes a5
yep
i don't know
hopefully that pawn is poison
hope jess
hopefully it's poison
very fuzzy play here by me fuzzy
f4 is working i don't know
i want to get an e5 instead of c3 i
should have played e5 and this would
have been a different world
whether or not that means i'm better i
don't know but c3 was not
well timed
is what i'm trying to say
all right
yeah so do i just end up in a crazy pin
is that what you're telling me
i don't know let's jump around with the
knight
seems cozy on b5
going for more
let's jump around again
all right so i'm down upon in this rook
ending
let's go to
i want to be able to target that pawn
one priority get that apon they're gonna
get my b-pawn in return
it's a good move
best i could hope for is what i don't
know
i don't know
oh
that was a bit of a gift
that should definitely be a draw
wow
um
yeah
good game uh where are we at oh we're
back 10 the excellencies
ah
the back eight any last oh that might
have been my last game no last one kc
okay
the french
this one won't count i did it crossed my
mind
uh whether or not to berserk or not
i don't know though
all right it's kind of quiet
um
all right let's take
how do i get out of this pin
it's a bit annoying
all right they have an up
has an opportunity for uh
crush my king side but it's a little
airy over here as well so i don't know
exactly how to assess it
i'd like to play bishop b4 eliminate the
knight and then jump in here i have to
invest many tempe i'm really thinking
about this as a next move getting out of
the pin
and then these kind of things
so he's probably crunching the numbers
on a chop here okay
i guess here
queen here is very active but i'm not
entirely sure what it is doing
what it would be doing
i'm gonna try this strategy
put a knight here if i could get an f6 i
should be better
and this is gonna be it all right so
let's
swing the bat around and jump in
i think i'm now the better side f6
nearby
kick him out now
let's see
they should be excellent for me
and i could consider a capture
i could block with my queen
cleaning f7
all right i think i want one rook off
maybe two
centralize the queen
no let's just fall back
let's get some majors off
put my queen on d5 in the end
this is covered against any check
could still return
on my king here
especially with the queens off
okay
let's get active
some checks clean on this square
queen on c4
could have considered a check in winning
this pawn
not anymore
it's a good move
offering a draw it's tempting i'm going
to play on
oh now i want to draw
i should have considered this move
i should be worse now
there's checks i got a block
probably should have taken the draw i
missed that move f5 is very strong
all right
oh they're giving me the f5 pawn
that's a good move
should be winning my knight should be
able to hunt these pawns
oh
like checkers there for a second
run pawn
can he be caught
he could be caught
c
should get this one
okay
where did we finish
seventh oh it was really close for sixth
okay
very good very very good
um
crestbook took it
with 1
607 points very nice oh they
they really
had a good cushion there
over fiona's fight club took second
penguin
fan club taking third
that's your top three
took seventh this time around
all right
uh let's see
i finished in 120th
how many games did i play
24 games
uh let's look at the top
top 100
penguin
114
very nice
114 points for the team
hans
second
hopper third
oh opera ended up playing for fiona's
fight club
all right let's see let's see the top
100
how many games are they getting in
penguin he did a lot of berserking
35 games
11 more than me
m sanchez chess you took first for the
team very nice yes 63 points
awesome man
thank you for playing coral
as well i think took second
and
was i in third for my team how did the
team finish no fourth
540 entered for the team awesome thank
you all very much
those of you who chose to compete in the
battle and play for team chess network
these are always a lot of fun
there's the top 20. i see pahovic there
pulling in 51 i had 58 63 62 59 58.
that's your top 20 and we could see the
top 50.
texas dave brazil we've played many
times nice to have you play
that's your top 50 coolio
i see you there
julio i believe is
subscriber here on twitch
thank you all again for
participating in this event it's always
a lot of fun
all right
good games
oh
you